[Music]
well thank you guys very much
I'm originally from Milwaukee Wisconsin
it's about right because I go that's
what they look like
originally from walking live here in Los
Angeles now and I live in kind of a
dangerous neighborhood actually there's
a Hispanic gang in the area or they like
to call themselves cholos which sounds
like a delicious snack treat sure it's
like a deep-fried pastry put sugar on it
that's a churro turn that into churro do
not put sugar on a cholo it'll confuse
them for a minute you can make a run for
it
but I'm at the the grocery store the
other day I see one of these cholo
fellas
and he's got one of these teardrop
tattoos you ever seen those which are
just adorable
but my buddy says that means he killed
somebody in the joint yeah well you know
what I think it means I think I mean
someone needs a hug
turns out I was wrong did not want a hug
be careful there gangs folks I don't
know if you know this if you're driving
at night you see somewhat their
headlights off do not flash them with
your headlights it's some sort of gang
initiation right they'll go after you so
now if I'm driving at night I see some
of their headlights off you know I I
shoot them
[Applause]
safety first you know all right ah see
so uh living out here I actually
experienced my first earthquake a few
months ago and a little embarrassing
right after it happen you know right
away I started looting things are a
little awkward around the apartment
complex I'm having to return items to
neighbors yeah I thought that was a big
one I I thought there'd be no survivors
to be quite honest I don't know what a
3.2 is here's your cat so I do come from
a long line of show business people
actually my great-great-grandfather was
actually a civil war re-enactor during
the Civil War
a little out of his time a little ahead
of his time my parents are my parents
are older older older than me
your parents are younger your probably
adopted but they are and growing up they
were very homophobic very homo
I'm sorry they're very homophobic they
hated words that sounded the same about
something completely different
[Applause]
I uh hey now the gay-marriage they
approve that finally and I'm assuming
I'm assuming we're all against it now I
know here's my that I like gay people
because gay people get to call their
loved ones partners you know like
they're detectives or something like I'm
Troy this is my partner Randy we're
gonna solve this murder then we're gonna
do it make it easier and II know I I'm
not a very smart guy is kind of a dumb
kid and like I always had trouble with
math like like the multiplication tables
so what I would do is I would associate
the numbers with things that I knew so
so take the problem like seven times
seven I would take seven cast aways on
Gilligan's Island who was a star of
Gilligan's Island Bob Denver
Denver's in Colorado when you think of
Colorado what do you think of mountains
mountains and Spanish is Montaigne
switch's fell the same as Montana who's
the most famous Montana Joe Montana who
played for the 49ers
that'll work for any math problem I
would do another one but there's no no
time no I I like to have fun folks
here's something fun to get next time
somebody calls you know it's a wrong
number here's what you do they ask you
for someone who isn't there you ask them
for someone who is in there so make us
bill they're like no is Todd over there
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography